MALE SPEAKER: Good morning
and welcome to Talks at Google
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Today it is my great pleasure
to introduce Dr. Anna
Frebel of Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
where she is Assistant Professor
in the Department of Physics.
She is here today to
discuss her book "Searching
for the Older Stars--
Ancient Relics
From the Early Universe."
Why do we care?
Because if it's not lithium,
hydrogen, or helium,
it came from these stars.
Dr. Frebel herself,
along with colleagues,
is responsible for discovering
many of these stars.
And in her book she
discovers the process
by which she does it.
The book itself is one of
the rare books in which we
get a dose of actual
science in terms
that both experts and lay
people can understand,
as well as a great
behind the scenes
look at what's involved
marathon observatory
sessions to discover
the stars and map them.
So without further
ado, please join me
in welcoming Dr. Anna Frebel.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNA FREBEL: Thank you so much
for the great introduction.
I'm very excited to be her
and to talk about my book.
It's been in the making
for quite a while.
So I'm really pleased
that it's finally out.
And it really got very exciting.
So I wanted to quickly introduce
and tell you a little bit what
my goal was of all these years.
Of course I'm a
scientist, but I'm
very interested in
conveying my research
results, but also the scientific
method to the wider audience.
And in this case, I
have to quote my mom,
because I regularly tell her
oh, I'm going to the telescope.
I'm going observing.
And she always says, yeah, yeah.
Now, after having
written the book
and of course her reading
it in great detail,
she really understands
what this means.
And the point of this is
that the public really
doesn't know what
scientists do all day long.
And this thing of going
observing and using telescopes
is certainly very
mysterious to anyone who
hasn't been at the telescope.
And there are even lots
of astronomers who haven't
been at a big telescope.
So this is really
a widespread issue.
And so I wanted to
write a book that is not
your typical popular
science book that presents
just the scientific results.
But I also wanted to tell the
story of how we get there.
As it turns out, it's never
really a straight line path.
And so the big windy
road is characterized
by good luck and bad luck, and
many other interesting things.
And so I have devoted several
chapters to that journey.
And so my motto is the journey
is the destination because I
became a scientist because
I wanted to find things out
and not necessarily to have
the flashiest of results.
Obviously that's really
great when that happens.
And it's a part of the
journey, the destination.
But really what I do on a daily
basis is not all that flashy.
But it's nevertheless
really interesting.
And so I want to give
a realistic insight
into what astronomers
do on a daily basis.
So let's get the story started.
Let's start right
at the beginning
some 14 billion years ago.
So the Big Bang occurred
And the universe at
that time consisted
of just three elements--
hydrogen, helium, and lithium.
And from that primordial gas,
the very first stars emerged.
And they were made from
hydrogen, helium, and lithium,
and nothing else.
Now these stars had
very short lives
because they have
a very high mass.
I'll touch on that a
little bit later again.
So they were short lived.
And when they exploded
as gigantic supernovae,
the elements that they
had been cooking up,
the additional elements that
they had been cooking up
in their cores to
sustain their luminosity,
to shine, even for
their short lives,
they were expelled into
the interstellar medium,
into the universe.
And that changed everything
because now the universe
consisted not just of hydrogen
and helium and lithium,
but also of elements like
carbon and oxygen and iron.
And that has a whole
lot of ramifications
for additional star formation
and also for galaxy formation.
So clearly these stars ushered
in a new era in the universe.
And then star and
galaxy formation indeed
had a chance to take off.
So we have this slightly
enriched material here.
And from that the next
generations of stars formed.
And it's actually those
early generations-- here
the second one in
particular that we
are trying to find-- because
these stars here now,
or some of these stars
in that generation
included low mass stars,
small, little stars.
And they have a
very long lifetime.
So they are still around today.
And those are the guys
that we are hunting down
with our big telescopes.
So I want to tell you
more about how we do that
and what we learn from
finding these stars.
But first let's talk a little
bit about chemical evolution.
That is the successive
buildup of heavy elements--
heavier than hydrogen, helium,
lithium-- in the universe
over billions of years.
Imagine that this here is
the primordial gas cloud,
so just what was there
after the Big Bang.
And the very first stars formed.
And they evolved.
And they exploded as supernovae.
And so the elements
that they cooked up
inside their cores
for energy production,
they got ejected back
into the reservoir here.
Then this is enriched
a little bit.
You form the next
generation of stars.
And then it goes round
and round and round.
And there are
several consequences.
You can immediately see that
you have this cycle here only
go around only a few times
as opposed to a few hundred
or thousand times,
that the amount
of the heavy elements in the
resulting stars will increase.
So older stars contain
much fewer of the elements.
And the younger
ones contain more.
And the sun, for reference,
also formed at some point,
probably when the cycle had gone
around maybe a thousand times
in this local region where
the sun formed later.
And the sun contains-- I'll
have another slide on that--
contains a whole 1.4%
of the heavy elements.
So that's already a lot.
But I'll say a little bit
more about this in a second.
So our primary goal is, when
we search for the oldest stars,
is to look for the
stars with the least
amount of heavy elements in
them because as it turns out,
it's incredibly difficult
to actually obtain
an actual age for the star.
However, at the very end,
I'll show you one example
where we managed to do that.
So that kind of
wraps it all up nice.
So we have to talk about
stellar chemical compositions.
And for reference
here I have at the top
the composition of the
universe after the Big Bang.
I've already mentioned this.
We have hydrogen, 75%, 25%,
and just a tiny sprinkle
of lithium.
So I excluded that
because actually it's
not too relevant for the
remainder of my talk.
And then after about 9 billion
years of chemical evolution,
the sun formed.
That was about 4.6
billion years ago.
And you can see how the
composition changed.
Hydrogen got convert
it into helium,
and helium got converted
into heavy elements.
So the sun is very
rich in heavy elements,
comparatively, a whole 1.4%.
And so what we're
doing is we are
looking for stars that have a
million times less than this.
So a whole different
ball game, but that
gives you an idea of what the
ranges we're playing with.
So there are a lot of chemical
elements in the periodic table.
Here a few illustrated.
I hope your little
coffee shop over there
will soon sell element cupcakes.
I'm sure they will taste
particularly sweet.
They certainly would to me.
A few are highlighted here, C,
N, O, P, S, and N-- oh sorry,
C, N, O, P, S-- that are
the elements of life.
As humans, we consist
mostly of carbon.
All life forms are carbon based.
And in particular, of
these five elements here.
But we contain also a whole
bunch of other elements.
And all that material of course
needs to come from somewhere.
And I already mentioned
that stars produce
elements for energy production.
But one thing that
is often forgotten
is that we actually also carry
a little Big Bang material in us
because our bodies
consists 90% of water.
And water is made of
hydrogen and oxygen.
And those protons
in the hydrogen,
they were certainly
recycled through stars.
But they were made
in the Big Bang.
And so we're not just
children of the stars,
but also children
of the Big Bang.
And so I think
that's really nice
that we can feel a little
connected to the beginning.
And so I already mentioned
here just a few pretty pictures
because in every
astronomy talk, you also
need a few pretty pictures.
This is a star
forming region here.
But the elements are
not just made in stars.
They're also made in
supernova explosions.
Here are a few examples of
various so-called supernova
remnants.
So they are just the shells
of heavy element material
that are still expanding
since the explosion.
And you can actually see in
the different colors here,
they are depicting
different elements.
So you can literally witness
how these new elements that
are produced in stars
and supernova explosions
are being dispersed
into the cosmos.
Here is another version
of the periodic table.
You can see that
I'm ready for lunch,
because I like somewhat
unusual depictions
of the periodic table
of the elements.
But then I'm also not a
chemist, I'm an astronomer.
We take a unique spin
on the periodic table
because you probably know
from your chemistry classes
that in chemistry here,
according to the colors,
the columns are very
important in chemistry
because the elements in a
column have similar properties.
As an astronomer, I couldn't
care less about the columns.
I care about the rows because
the elements are subsequently
made.
If you want to
create iron here, you
have to create these
guys here beforehand.
So it goes one to
one to one to one
to get where you have to go.
So we care for the rows.
And so maybe I have
to soon bake one
of those 109 cupcakes colored
in a slightly different way.
Let's get to the
heart of the matter.
So my work is often
called stellar archaeology
because we take these survivor
stars that are in the Milky Way
today, and we study their
chemical composition so that we
can [INAUDIBLE] their age, or
at least their formation era,
due to the small amounts
of heavy elements in them.
And from that, we
can then infer what
the composition
of this gas cloud
was this little guy formed from.
And that tells us
what exactly came out
of one of those first
star supernova explosions.
Because as I said
in the beginning,
these guys here are very
massive and short lived.
So we can actually not
study them anymore.
The only way we can do this
is through this indirect way
of looking at their
stellar genes that
are incorporated into the
next generation of star.
So obviously that
requires that we
have to find these second
generation stars here.
But we are finding them now.
And so we can infer properties
of these very first stars
that really shaped the
universe at this early time.
So where do we find these stars?
Let's look at the
Milky Way for a second.
Here is a top view.
And we live in a spiral galaxy.
This is the galactic center.
It's very brightly lit.
You can actually see it here.
This is what we see on the
sky because we sit over here
about 2/3 on the way out.
And in the northern
hemisphere from here,
we are actually looking out.
So what we see on the sky
is this spiral arm here.
Whereas if we go to the
southern hemisphere,
we look in that direction and
we see that spiral arm here.
But it's backlit by
the galactic center.
And that's why the Milky Way
is so much better in the south.
And this is a
picture of the south.
So you can see the back lighting
of the galactic center here.
And here is a
further edge on view.
What I want to focus
on now is actually
not the disk itself at
all, but this outer region
here that we call
the halo, which
is very thinly populated
spherical envelope that
kind of protects and
swirls around the disk.
And we have lots of
things living in their,
little old halo stars.
And those are the
ones we want to find.
It's a little bit like
the junkyard of the galaxy
actually.
And we also have
little dwarf galaxies
that are orbiting the
Milky Way as well.
And we study those as well.
So I told you a little
bit about stars now
and that they are old.
You can probably
guess that they're
not very rare, because a lot of
stars have formed since then.
So I want to put this
to a test with you.
Who can tell me which one's
the oldest one in here?
I'll give you a hint, it's not
this guy here in the middle.
That would be too easy.
There can only be
wrong answers here.
Actually, they will
likely be wrong,
but why don't you give it a try.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The reddest one.
ANNA FREBEL: The reddest one.
Why do we have red one?
We have a red one here.
This one?
Perhaps this one here.
OK, well it's not
the reddest one.
Maybe the bluest one?
Pardon?
AUDIENCE: You said they
were small, [INAUDIBLE].
ANNA FREBEL: That's a
good deduction, yeah.
However, if you put
a star further away,
it'll appear smaller.
So from this collective image
here, we can't really tell.
Well I can tell you one thing.
I have absolutely no
clue which star is old
and which star is young.
All we can see in this
image, all that you have seen
is that there are
different apparent sizes
and different colors.
Because a picture like that
is really not giving you
any more information.
Now that's really
good information,
but it's limited information.
What do we need to do?
Well we need to use a
different technique,
and it's called spectroscopy.
It doesn't deliver
pretty pictures.
But oh boy, it
delivers information.
And you guys hopefully
appreciate that.
So we use the method
of spectroscopy
to explore the outer
atmosphere of the star.
And with that we can bridge
very large distances.
And it's almost
like we're taking
a little piece of
the star and looking
at it in the lab, kind
of like the CSI guys
and their mass spectrometers.
We use big telescopes for that.
But before telling you a
little bit more about that,
I just wanted to
make one more point,
namely a picture is
worth a thousand words,
but a spectrum is worth
a thousand pictures.
Because this is a
star-- this is a picture
of a very important star.
But when you look
at the picture,
it's a fuzzy blob
in the universe.
How boring.
It's incredibly boring.
It doesn't really
tell us anything.
But the spectroscopic
analysis has
revealed that this is the by
now second most iron poor star.
So this is a second generation
star in the universe.
That's pretty neat I think.
So let's briefly recap
what we do in terms
of a chemical balance analysis.
That is based on a spectrum.
We collect the starlight
with a big telescope.
And we have a
spectrograph, which
is basically a prism here.
So the prism splits up the
light into the rainbow colors,
and then you get a
spectrum like that.
It doesn't look quite
like the rainbow
because there are all
these dark lines in here.
And each dark line refers
to a little piece of light
that is lost.
And what's happening
in the stellar surface
that we are all
observing, there are
all sorts of elements,
atoms, swirling around.
And each element absorbs
at certain wavelengths.
And well, absorption means
that the light is absorbed.
It's gone.
And so that's why we
see these lines here.
And actually a cross cut
through here is shown up here.
You can see all of
these lines here.
These are all absorption lines.
And if we take a little
peek, a closer look here,
we have hydrogen lines here.
And here's even a
tiny calcium line.
So we can measure the
strength of these lines
and then infer their abundance.
Because that's really what we
want in order to determine OK,
how much of these heavy
elements is there,
and is that a star
that could have formed
as part of the second generation
because it's abundances are
low.
And so I already hinted at
that these stars are very rare.
They formed 13
billion years ago.
And since then, the universe has
been quite busy making stars.
And so we need a big sky surveys
to go from hundreds-- sorry,
from millions, actually
hundreds of millions almost,
stars, to actual
hundreds and then dozens.
And we do that by getting
different kinds of spectra.
And the quality goes up and up.
We really need very high
resolution spectra here
which just means
we really stretch
the light out to an extreme
to get to really, really
fine spectral details here.
So we can measure this
tiny little iron line here.
And here's another one.
This is the calcium line
here-- to do our work.
So it's quite painstaking.
And it takes years sometimes
to go from here to here.
But it's really awesome
when we get there.
And so let me tell you a
little bit about the observing
because it's absolutely
fascinating to go there
and to take your data and
have these discovery moments.
And so that was
something that I really
wanted to share with everyone.
And so here are just a few
pictures of big telescopes
that I have used.
I will tell you
a little bit more
about the Magellan
telescopes here.
These are the Keck
telescopes on Hawaii.
Maybe you have been to Hawaii.
You can even go up the summit,
almost up to the summit
and take a telescope tour
if you're ever there.
The Japanese telescopes
also up on Mauna Kea,
and then also in Chile some
of the European telescopes.
So lots out there.
And here are the
Magellan telescopes.
I take students there.
This was an undergrad at MIT.
So I like to train students
also from early on.
And I have won some extra
funds to take specifically
undergrads to the telescope
to give them the research
experience very early on.
It's very inspiring to them.
And so far they've all gone into
science, or stuck with science.
And it's been always
very exciting.
So I really love
going there, even when
it's cloudy like this.
But it doesn't make
for pretty pictures.
And that's how it
looks at night.
This isn't even the center
part of the Milky Way, just
the spiral arm part here,
the non backlit part.
The galactic center
is sort of down here.
I was observing some
dwarf galaxy stars
with that telescope while
I had to stand very still
for 30 seconds.
So that was exciting.
But let me show you some--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[BIRDS CHIRPING]
ANNA FREBEL: --movies to really
give you the visual counterpart
to what I describe in the book.
So theses are the
two telescopes.
This is sort of mine,
the one I always use.
And you can see the
Milky way now moving up.
And you can clearly see the
backlit spiral arm here.
This is the galactic center.
And it's just
absolutely majestic.
And actually if the
moon is down and you
have the Milky
Way above you, you
can see your own shadow
in the light of the stars.
Just think about
that for a second.
That's just truly magical.
But the moon does come
up once in a while
and wrecks your time lapse.
But as I said, this is
about realistic experiences
and not fudge things
like it's always dark
and the Milky Way is up.
So I just wanted to
just show how it really
is, the good, the
bad, and the ugly.
[END PLAYBACK]
ANNA FREBEL: And I have another
one because this one was
the outside.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANNA FREBEL: But
what happens inside?
So a lot of screens, a lot of
keyboards, lots of buttons,
and lots of spectra.
And you'll see here
the round spectra.
They're not yet fully processed.
But you see the
absorption lines in them.
So I inspect the strength
of those absorption lines
immediately after
ever observations.
And it's yea or nay.
So either I go to the next
target or it's like oh, maybe I
need to take more care here.
[END PLAYBACK]
ANNA FREBEL: And yeah, that
happens all night long.
That's what astronomers
are doing all night long.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANNA FREBEL: But, as I
said, there's good luck
and there's bad luck.
I have been at the
telescope many times
and it was completely cloudy
and I came home empty handed.
I have to wait for a year
until I get time again
that I actually have to
competitively win first.
So sometimes the
universe is just
against you, or
the weather gods.
But again, it makes
for pretty pictures.
You can see here, this
is Scorpion, Antares.
So even through the
clouds, you can actually
see quite a lot of stars.
It just depends how
thick the clouds
are whether you keep
observing through the clouds
or you have to stop because
there's just nothing coming
through anymore,
like in this case.
Obviously it works
out to be artsy.
What you see here is, well,
the trucks on the highway.
Light pollution is a big
issue, even at the telescopes.
Every year I go there it
gets a little bit worse.
The cities get a
little bit bigger.
There are a little more
trucks on the road.
It's no good.
It's really affecting us.
And this is in Atacama
Desert at 2,500 metres
up in the mountains.
But we can see very far
because the air is so good.
And then it gets light
again in the morning.
[END PLAYBACK]
ANNA FREBEL: So if you
like these kinds of clips
or would like to show them
to someone else who might
be interested in
seeing what astronomers
are doing at big telescopes, you
can put my name into YouTube.
I guess you know how that works.
You can also tweet me or
just check out my website
as I have a whole
bunch of things there.
Because my outreach
program is called Science--
It's a Human Thing.
It's people who are
doing this, so we
should show people doing it.
Pretty simple, yet
apparently so difficult.
Back to the science.
So here is this picture
again, this fuzzy blob.
This is one of the most
important stars we have found.
As far as we know, it's
a second generation star
because its iron abundance
and other elements
are so deficient that only
one first star supernova is
required or needed to produce
all these elements that we
see in the star now.
I should say here
for clarification,
this star is actually
really unevolved.
It has not even
started yet converting
anything else but hydrogen
to helium in its core.
So this star has not really
made any heavy elements itself.
Whatever we find in the
stellar surface today
came from the birth gas cloud
from which the star formed,
which means it must have come
from that previous generation
star that enriched that gas.
So this is really the
pinnacle of our work.
And how much iron is in there?
Well, the star's obviously
a little bit bigger
than the Earth,
about 300,000 times.
But if you want to
make the comparison,
you take the Earth iron core.
And it's about 1%
of the Earth iron
core that is spread throughout
my little star there.
So that supernova produced
about that much, which
makes you think
like, could the Earth
have formed early
on in the universe?
Well the answer is clearly no
because you needed at least
100 supernovae to
produce as much iron
in the universe to even
make up the Earth iron core.
So it took probably
several billion years
before there was enough material
out there to have planets form.
That sort of transition of
when the first planets emerged
is currently researched, and
certainly a very, very exciting
topic.
And I look forward to
knowing the answer.
But no planets in
the early universe.
And so what do we
learn from this now?
I already mentioned
many tidbits.
So let's put this together.
So we usually use iron, but also
elements like carbon and oxygen
to try to figure out what
went on in the supernova.
And we work with people who
calculate how many elements
are produced by the star itself
as it does before it explodes,
and then in the
supernova explosion.
And we compare those models.
And then we figure out oh, it
was this and this much that
came out of this first star.
And this really is the one
and only diagnostic tool
that we have to study the
properties of the first stars.
So what are we interested in?
Well, first of all we're
interested in their masses,
because theory has actually told
us that these first stars were
very massive.
It's actually very
difficult for stars
to form from just hydrogen
and helium and lithium.
It can't really cool down,
so it can't be a clump well.
And so it's difficult
to make small stars.
So we would like to confirm
that the theorists are right
and that they have high
masses, maybe as [INAUDIBLE]
says, maybe up to 100
solar masses, 100 times
the mass of the sun.
And indeed our works,
from this comparison,
we have found that the first
stars might have been something
like 50 or 60 solar masses.
No, it's not exactly 100, but
that was just a ballpark number
to start with.
So it's definitely
more than 10 or 15,
which is a typical mass
for today's larger stars.
So kind of different back then.
But we can also learn about
the explosion mechanism
and the explosion energy.
And that is very important
for understanding really
how much power
these stars started
to change the universe
when they exploded.
There are all sorts
of ramifications
that come from that
depending on how
violently these stars exploded.
So we have a whole bunch
of ongoing sky surveys
that help us to find
more of these stars,
especially some that
involve a new technique that
is a lot more efficient now.
So hopefully we'll find a
lot more of these guys soon.
I think in the last
few minutes I'd
like to introduce this
second star to you.
Here's another fuzzy
blob in the universe.
Now this one is
actually fairly bright.
So if you have a small
telescope at home
or you know someone who
has, you can actually
take a picture yourself.
This was taken by an
amateur astronomer.
And he sent me
this picture there.
So that's kind of nice.
But again, you need that
spectroscopic knowledge
to say that this is one of
older stars we know because we
have measured its age.
So what's the big deal here?
We have taken a spectrum, and
the spectrum is very unusual
because it contains
absorption lines from very
heavy rare earth elements.
And that included elements
like thorium and uranium.
And you hopefully know that
these are radioactive elements.
So as soon as you deal
with radioactive material,
you have yourself a clock.
So we're making use of that.
And it basically works like
the radiocarbon method,
just we're dealing with
slightly older [INAUDIBLE].
So if you think that
this was the supernova,
these heavy elements
including, thorium, uranium,
they got produced here.
They got expelled
into the universe.
And then our little guy formed.
And all this material
got baked into the star.
And then actually, pretty much
since the supernova explosion,
the radioactive material
has started to decay.
And today we
measure what's left.
And we compared that
with calculations
for how much was produced.
And bang, we have an age.
That all sounds really easy.
And the concept is
very straightforward.
Before I show you
why this is so hard,
let me just
illustrate to you what
it means to work on some
of those special stars.
So here are a few elements
that we regularly measure
in all of our old stars.
We then have these purple ones
here, the rare earth elements,
especially the ones
here at the bottom,
that we can measure in there.
These elements are produced
only in supernova explosions
during very, very
special conditions.
So the gold and the
silver from your jewelry
all comes from these very
special supernova explosions.
And there are still a
lot of open questions
about this process that
makes these elements.
And so it's very exciting for
us to find some of these stars
so we can chime
into this question
where elements like silver
and gold actually come from
and how exactly they are
produced in the universe.
So here is why this
measurement takes
an incredible amount of data.
And it's a very
difficult analysis,
because we want to
measure uranium abundance.
And so here you have absorption
lines-- magnesium, iron,
neodymium, samarium, iron here.
And you see it's a
blow up [INAUDIBLE].
So if you look at
this blue line,
this is a synthetic
spectrum that we
have created to model the
star that contains no uranium.
And the question
is, does that one
correspond to the observed
data, which is the dots?
And clearly the answer is no.
Instead we have data that's
a little bit lower, which
means there is a little
uranium absorption.
And so we have then
created models that kind of
reproduce those here.
And if the uranium
was not decaying,
it would have been
absorbed up to here.
So that would be
easy to measure.
But it's good that it's decaying
because it gives us this clock.
So making this
measurement here requires
extremely exquisite data.
But it worked because
this star is bright.
And we got an age.
Well, this is not
precision cosmology,
but nevertheless it's an
important contribution
to the early universe or to
studies of the early universe.
And it confirms
that the whole story
I have told you about
the chemical composition
and they're telling us that
we can look back in time
to this early era by
measuring chemical abundances
is actually correct.
So here are different
elements ratios.
They all involve either
thorium, or uranium, or both.
And these are ages
in billion years.
Now the universe is
13.8 billion years.
So this is just a mathematical
number that pops out.
Obviously it's
unphysical, but math
doesn't care about physics.
So we have to take it.
But if you average
all of this, it
comes out to about
13 billion years.
And that is the number we like.
It's very consistent with
the age of the universe.
Now there are some uncertainties
of course, but it is not 10,
and it's not 5 billion years.
It's not like the sun.
And even 10 is still a
while away from 14 here.
So the concept of stellar
archaeology is correct.
It works.
And these old stars, first
of all, they really are old.
And we can use them to
explore the early universe.
And of course before the
era of these satellites that
probe the cosmic microwave
background radiation,
and that led to the very
precise determination of the age
of the universe to 13.8 billion
years, methods like these
were the standard
to date the universe
and to provide a lower limit
to the age of the universe.
So when I went to high school,
that was still the standard.
And this would have made
a great addition then.
OK, so that brings
me to the end of it.
I hope I could give you just a
tiny little bit of an insight
that these old stars really
are like little diamonds
in the sky.
They are very rare.
They are difficult to come
by, but we have our methods.
I didn't have time to
talk much about this,
but many contain actually
unusually large amounts
of carbon compared to
the other elements.
And that actually
indicates to us
that carbon is not just an
important element for us today,
since we're all carbon based,
but it was probably also
the most important element that
helped in the early universe
after the formation
of the first stars.
So carbon really is the
most important element
if you ask me at
all cosmic times.
And well, these
stars are quite old.
So I would say they last
almost until forever.
And we can address, in theory,
many different and exciting
science questions with them.
So there's almost an old
star for any kind of question
you might have.
And of course when you find
them, they make you happy.
So I would just say-- and
my slides a little cut
off there-- with our
new and ongoing service
and the big telescopes
that we're using,
we are continuing
this treasure hunt.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So how many of
these second generation
stars are known now?
ANNA FREBEL: So I think we
know about six, five or six.
It depends a little
bit on who you ask,
and it also depends a little
bit on the type of first star
supernova that you're modeling
and how much it outputs.
So there are obviously
a little variation.
But we've come really a long
while, because in 2000, there
were zero.
So OK, that's 15 years ago.
But with our increasingly
improving search techniques,
it's now kind of on the rise.
AUDIENCE: And you
mentioned that we've
learned things about the
first generation of stars.
Is there any prospect
that someday we
will have a telescope that
will let us actually see
some of these first
generation stars?
ANNA FREBEL: Well
for that we would
need to have a strong infrared
telescope like the James Webb
Space Telescope that's
currently being built by NASA.
People have made
this calculation
whether you could look
far enough back in time
that you would essentially
look back to that era,
because the light that
comes from this early era
just travels for 13 something
billion years to us.
So if you can look
that far back,
that would be really awesome.
Now that would be
really, really, really
far away, which means you
really need really, really
bright sources.
And while the first stars,
very, very bright, individually
they're not bright
enough to shine over
13.8 billion light years.
However, maybe if there was
a cluster of first stars
together, that could
just be bright enough.
We don't know.
But it's very speculative.
And again, as [INAUDIBLE]
theorists have calculated that.
God bless them.
But we'll have to see
how that matches up
with the capabilities of
a telescope like the JWST.
AUDIENCE: The stars
that you described
seem to have low mass.
Is this typical of
what you would predict,
or do you think it's selection
bias from your search?
ANNA FREBEL: It's
absolutely a selection bias
because stellar mass correlates
inversely with lifetime.
So the big guys,
they die very soon.
And the little guys
live very long.
So we can only find old staffs
that are of very low mass.
And to give you a reference, the
sun, and to use the solar mass,
the mass of the
sun as a reference,
has a lifetime of
10 billion years.
That's actually
easy to remember.
And so the guys that we
are interested in now
have about 0.6 to
0.8 solar masses
because they have total
lifetimes of 15 to 20
billion years.
So if they're formed
14 billion years ago,
they still have a while
to go, but not that long.
And so they are just in the
right evolutionary state
right now for us to find
them and to not have
messed up their surfaces
from the interior
and doing all sorts
of other wonky things.
So yeah, it's kind of by design.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So you mentioned that the
first generation of stars
are very massive,
like 100 solar mass.
And the one you presented is
much lighter, like 0.6 or 0.8.
And consequently there's a huge
difference in their lifetime
because the first
generation died very fast.
And this one is 13
billion years old.
But they are not very
different in terms
of the amount of
heavier elements in them
because, as you said, there's
only a teeny tiny amount
in this one, and there is zero
in the first generation one.
So it doesn't really seem a
striking difference to me.
Why is it that very teeny tiny
amount of heavier elements
can make such a big difference
in the mass of forming stars?
ANNA FREBEL: Thank
you for asking that,
because I usually don't have
time to talk about that.
So zero or little
makes a big difference
because heavy elements,
especially carbon and oxygen,
they act as coolants.
So imagine you have this soup.
And the soup just can't cool.
You add just a sprinkle of
salt, well in this case,
you change the whole
flavor of your soup.
It goes from bland to tasty.
And the same kind
of thing happens
when you add a little carbon.
It suddenly can cool
and it can clump.
And it can fragment.
And once you have
fragmentation, the cloud
breaks up into smaller clumps.
And then gravity will
again do its thing,
but on smaller length scales.
It's a little bit more
complicated than that,
but that's the basic idea.
So as soon as you have some
elements-- because you know,
carbon is a more extended
complicated atom.
So it has a lot of
transitions for the electrons.
And they're just kind
of wiggling away.
And carbon and oxygen
are particularly
good at having so-called fine
structure line transitions.
So it can wiggle, whereas
a hydrogen atom really, it
can do nothing.
I mean, it has one
electron going around.
I mean, the cooling
mostly comes from H2.
So you have two electrons
because you have two protons,
or HD.
So it's a little bit
better than that.
But you see the difference.
So as soon as you have
even a few atoms in there,
they radiate away, which
means they send out photons
that can leave the gas cloud.
And poof, your energy gone.
So this is some critical
metallicity, so critical amount
of elements that you need.
It's very, very low, but really
it ushers in this transition.
AUDIENCE: Please
correct me if I'm wrong,
but I imagine that what
you see in the spectrum
is basically determined
by the composition
of the surface of the star.
Do we know to what extent
that matches the distribution
of elements in the whole star?
ANNA FREBEL: Yeah,
that's a great question.
And that's always the concern.
So that's why we
have to make sure
that we catch the stars in
the right evolutionary phase.
To back up a little bit, people
have done for a long time--
actually, that was the
beginning of astrophysics
with a computer.
They have calculated the
evolutionary paths of stars.
So stars evolve.
They get born.
They start to burn
hydrogen to helium.
Later on they burn helium
to heavier elements.
And so there is a
whole sequence that
also correlates to how the
star looks from the outside.
It changes color.
It changes size as a function
of what's going on inside.
And so we know very well at
what time the star gets mixed
and whether the outer
layers actually realize
what's happening inside.
So our stars, it's the
case that the outer layers
don't realize at all what's
going on in the center
because they are
just burning hydrogen
to helium in the center.
And the outer layers
really don't care
at all what's happening there.
They just sit there undisturbed
for billions of years because
of their very slow evolution.
If we had, let's
say, a 0.9 solar mass
star, that would evolve faster.
And if we would see it today,
it would still be alive,
but it would have
already started
to burn helium into carbon.
And in the process of
that, the star gets mixed.
And the carbon from the
interior gets indeed transported
to the outer layers.
So we call that self-enrichment.
And that's also very
interesting to study.
But for stellar
archaeology, that's
a big no no because then
we can't transfer anymore
what we see today to what
the composition was before.
AUDIENCE: My sister-in-law was
a telescope driver at Kitt Peak.
And often the scientists weren't
actually necessarily there.
And I expect a lot of
times, as a scientist,
you don't actually have to
ever get near the telescopes
for these observations to occur.
How frequently do you go?
And do you go for practical
reasons, or just because it's--
ANNA FREBEL: Well actually
all of the above, sort of.
So it's true.
Most telescopes these days
have professional operators.
And the astronomer doesn't
even need to go there anymore.
Certainly all of the big
ones except for the Magellan
telescopes that I'm using.
They have the old school policy
that if you want to take data,
you've got to better
do it yourself.
And for our discovery work,
that is actually very beneficial
because I need to inspect the
data right there and right then
because the stars
are not observable
all night long because
they are standing
steady above my telescope.
They are moving.
And if I want to keep
catching the star
because it turned out to
be really interesting,
so we take a quick
exposure first.
And we inspect it because we
only deal with candidates.
And so we then have to make
the decision, yea or nay.
So that has to happen fast.
If someone was to
take the data and then
we would get it the next day,
and then we'll look at it.
It might not be
observable anymore.
The weather might turn bad.
That kind of moment
just kind of goes.
And so for us, it's very
good to be at the telescope
and focus 100% percent
on that and get our data.
Now I travel to Chile about
two or three times a year.
It takes a long
time to get there,
something like three hours.
And I always feel like I
need a vacation coming back
because you work all night long.
You have to switch 12 hours,
working from days then nights.
In between you have night
over flights down there.
So that's no fun.
But being there is a lot of fun.
And then having the
data is a lot of fun.
But I do really think that
it's important for at least
every student to
go to a telescope
once to see the process.
But with all these
big new sky surveys,
people just download the
data from the internet now.
And I have come across
students who, A,
don't think the data is real
because it was downloaded
from the internet.
It was like faked.
Yeah sure, we can
make fake data.
We have.
That has certain purposes.
As a scientist, your work
is based on data collection.
And that has been
erased from astronomy.
Downloading data
from the internet
is not data collection,
at least not to me.
So that's another
reason why I really
enjoy going there
because it brings me back
to the root of my profession
and one of the reasons
why I wanted to become an
astronomer in the first place.
And being on the mountain
top, and seeing the sun down,
and having the mountains
that tinged in purple,
and having the night
sky above me, I mean,
that's just priceless
on top of that.
AUDIENCE: So I noticed
you use heavier elements.
You don't say metals.
Is that because you're talking
to the public and astronomers
have hydrogen, helium, and
then metals for everything
else, right?
ANNA FREBEL: I took
that slide out.
I had to cut a few slides.
You want me to elaborate, or--
AUDIENCE: You go
into it in the book?
ANNA FREBEL: Yes, I am.
Because I do believe that
with sufficient explanation
and motivation, the public can
understand a lot of details.
You just got to
walk them through.
So what we're talking about
is that astronomers are not
chemists, so we can do
pretty much whatever we want.
And the universe is a complex
and complicated place.
So a long time ago,
someone came up
with a grandiose idea of lumping
all the chemical elements
into one thing.
And so they're called hydrogen
because the universe is
full of hydrogen, X. Then
helium is the second most common
element.
They called it Y. And
then all the rest,
that's kind of negligible.
That's Z. So if your
dinner conversation ever
goes stale, just tell them,
what's the universe made of?
XYZ, haha.
So we look for the
stars with the least
amount of heavy
elements in them,
which means we look for stars
that are poor in metals,
all of the elements.
So we call them
metal poor stars.
So that's the jargon.
But usually unless I give a long
talk, so in my hour long talks
I do it.
But in the shorter ones
I usually cut it out.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]